je
moore
chez nous
salut à tous et bienvenue attendu pour
vous parler d'une discipline qui pèsent
sur ces de 10 me licencier 47 clubs et
terrain un peu partout sur l'île et pour
nous en parler et les guiraud directeur
sportif du 17e étape assure c'est quoi
il rit le tennis c'est parti
ce directeur sportif est un animateur
incontournable du club municipal du
tampon d'un des plus gros clubs de l'île
avec 1266 licenciés entre natation et
tennis autour du terrain
en mélangeant un petit peu pour ce pas
chasser recul
allez c'est parti
moi donc ça a été très facile et j'ai
traversé un petit chemin et je suis allé
dans le club de tennis qui était à côté
de chez moi donc je sais pas j'ai pas eu
trop de mérite mais pourquoi c'est
pourquoi cette discipline est membre a
le oui la télé un petit peu de 3
champion emblématique à l'époque et puis
et puis voilà c'est ça part comme ça
le mercredi midi c'est le moment où tous
les enseignants se retrouvent pour faire
un point d'étape
quelques minutes à peine pour marcher
dans la même direction celle du club
ne vous enflammez pas sur le rythme avec
une bonne marge de sécurité
il était important de ne pas rater
d'accord et de jouer lentement très bien
on se replace
chacun prend possession des ponts
secours
baby tennis débute en loisir une
compétiteurs cette association répond
aux objectifs de tous ces sportifs
bah pour moi c'est d'essayer de devenir
comment dire professionnel je joue déjà
pour m'habiller et si je peux devenir
très très bon bah c'est vraiment super
bien mais je vise pas d'être dans les
meilleurs mondiaux d'être comme federer
est tout et jouant bien m'investir là
dedans c'est une formule cette élite
formée au club à 15 ans de moyenne d'âge
mais étonnamment tous ne rêvent pas de
carrière tennistique c'est le cas de eva
payet classé 2/6 une des meilleures
féminines de lille
peuchère les deux